الذكاء الاصطناعي قد يكون اكبر تهديد
للبشريه هذا وفقا لرؤساء تنفيذيين لاكبر
الشركات التكنولوجيه الرائده في العالم
ففي بيان مشترك قال اكثر من 350 مسؤولا في
شركات كبرى من بينهم مبتكرات تشاد جي بي
تي قالوا ان مخاطر الذكاء الاصطناعي يجب
ان تعامل باولويه قصوى طبعا الى جانب
المخاطر المجتمعيه الاخرى كالوبئه والحرب
النوويه خاصه ان نماذج كتشات جي بي تي قد
تستخدم لنشر المعلومات الخاطئه وايضا
الجرائم الالكترونيه فضلا عن التسبب في
تعطيل الوظائف لدرجه ان تحل محل الانسان
او تدمر البشريه عن غير قصد المخاوف لم
تقتصر على ذلك اذ حذر اكاديميون اخرون من
تهديدات اكثر خطوره كسريع الذكاء
الاصطناعي الى انهيار الحضاره وايضا الى
تاكل الديمقراطيه وحتى الى امكانيه
استخدامه من قبل البشر لتصميم اسلحه
بيولوجيه او وهو الاخطر نتحدث هنا عن
قنبله نوويه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات